guys good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever you're from thanks for
joining this this very special
livestream we're gonna do something
really awesome today so I just explained
this before I went live here but we're
gonna do it again so basically guys we
got something really special going on
there's a bunch of free models that I
uploaded for you guys in the description
of this video make sure you download
those models they're free I packaged
them up for you guys for this specific
render challenge that we're gonna do
over the next couple hours so download
your models load them up into c40
blender 3ds maya whatever you're using
download those models and do not start
yet do not start yet because once you
have your models downloaded and they're
looking nice basically what we're gonna
do is we have two hours to model and
written up model we have two hours to
render an awesome image it has to be it
must be posted within the two hour limit
to anywhere it could be anywhere can be
Twitter reddit Facebook the discord
channel that we got set up here so
Demonte he's in the chat he can't join
us for the entire stream but uh he took
this channel to the next level the
discord channel link is in the
description of this live stream right
now so be sure to go there hop on in
there's some people in the voice Channel
voice chat right now hop in with those
guys
and let's all just make something
awesome together with these models
provided most importantly download those
models download those models yes
Provence you province you it is a people
challenge it is a people challenge that
exists is exactly what we're doing we
did this with people at corridor digital
he came over to the studio we had one
hour to make something awesome and post
it this time we got two hours to make
something awesome and post it and in the
description this
there's also a hashtag you guys can use
so we can collect all of our work
together we is there a hashtag there may
not be a hashtag just add me on on
Instagram it's at underscore poni sure
underscore there you go
download those models hey and guys you
know what if you don't have a 3d
modelling program guess what all right
you're gonna see the models we're
looking at here I challenge you to draw
something I challenge you to build some
Legos whatever it is because here's the
thing guys we're all kind of trapped in
our houses most of us are in quarantine
self quarantine or we have no other
choice we have to be in our house
because of the coronavirus right now so
this is a time that is pretty tough for
a lot of people there's only so long you
can be in your house locked up in your
house without going crazy so what we're
gonna do here today is two things we're
going to challenge ourself to make an
awesome render with the models provided
download the models right now they're in
the description of this thing we're
gonna challenge ourselves to do that
we're gonna have two hours all right so
we're gonna get creative during this
quarantine time all right we're gonna
make the most of the quarantine time
we're gonna make some cool art we're
going to learn some stuff for however
long this lasts let's keep making stuff
let's keep growing our skills as much as
possible learning as much as much as
possible and taking advantage of the
time given to us we have to be very
smart with the time given to us also
another thing we need to do is take care
of our bodies all right guys because
being like sitting down in the same
chair getting locked up in the same the
same room is pretty tough especially if
you don't move you can get to feel
pretty isolated pretty depressed pretty
locked down so in the spirit of getting
up and moving what I'm gonna challenge
you guys to do basically is every time
you guys super chat in the comments
here I'm gonna do ten burpees okay
that's five for me and five for you and
I challenge y'all to join me with those
burpees okay so every time you guys do
super chat no matter what the price no
matter anything none of that right okay
I'm doing 10 burpees for you guys
throughout the entire stream hopefully I
don't sabotage myself this might get
difficult but in the spirit of getting
up and moving our butts and being
healthy and not being cooped up we got
to work out we got to exercise because
that's the only way that we're gonna be
able to basically you know stay sane in
these times when we're just isolated in
our house unreal
asks hey can this be a regular thing a
render challenge maybe let's see how
this goes let's see if this does well
and I do need y'all's help when other
people are joining you know we still got
people joining the stream right now fill
them in on what's going down
it's a render challenge we got two hours
download the models let's get going
every super check gets ten burpees we're
gonna do them together and because I'm
gonna be focused on this render here I
this is gonna be pretty tough you know
we got two hours to make something
awesome and has to be posted posted
within two hours and it's gonna be
awesome so give me a shout guys who who
has their models downloaded right now
who is ready to go right now by show of
comes ups by a show of maybe smiley
faces who has their models downloaded
and is ready to get going
all right for people not bad 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 this is awesome guys
heck yeah oh X particles everybody's
ready
Oh first super chatzi CG studios how
high or how are you I wish Ren would be
here
work from home everybody that's right so
yeah Ren will not be here because we're
all in quarantine but I got to do 10
burpees now because of the first super
chat see if y'all can see these we're
get proper form here you know I'm saying
keeping me healthy
how's that for those of you don't know a
burpee yeah is a push up in a jumping
jack and i've lost count at this point I
think that's ten and an almond at the
end down it's gonna be rough
okay so yeah every super chair gets ten
burpees because we got to stay active
during these times of quarantine um
goodness okay this might be this might
be bad okay we got 84 people up in here
y'all if you don't know what we're doing
already we're doing a render challenge
all right there are models in the
description of this video download them
okay you can only use those models
unless you model something on the spot
okay um yeah what was I saying
you can only use those models guys we
got two hours when I start a timer here
but let's go through all these models
together and see what we got okay
oh goodness all right
first first things first
we got a we got a cat first things up is
a cat boom that's the first thing let's
keep going through we have not started
the timer yet oh my god P ghost cheese
alright ten more for you guys get those
models loaded into your modeling program
okay I'm going to do ten more burpees
pray for me I'll see you guys in a
second go ahead new ten burpees but
that's cool because I needed to do them
and I've lost count again
I think I got like two more
dude I'm so done for in the almond okay
yes this is the people challenge the
people challenge hmm okay
let's keep going geez oh alright
um let's keep going through our models
Oh what else do we have we have a cat we
have an old and old steel bucket guys
ooh this thing just this just roll
classic steel bucket
who knows if these things are to scale
we shall see let's keep going
wait do we have it am I even in the
right folder we don't have an old steel
bucket guys what am I saying but we do
have a crow I'm gonna try not to breathe
into this mic you know what guys no
there's no I'm passing away already
there's no USD limit on these uh burpees
here guys we gotta stay healthy and fit
oh this is gonna be intense we're gonna
start that to our time hey if you guys
are just joining gel are just joining
we're doing a to our render challenge
we're gonna start the timer very soon
here download your models okay they're
in the description of this video and for
every super every super chat I'm doing
I'm still out of breath I'm doing 10
burpees because we got to stay active in
these times of quarantine y'all um okay
let's keep let's keep going loading in
these models here we got a dresser look
at that okay
oh come on come on let's open this thing
up I'm not even I'm not even gonna
texture these things right now because I
don't know what I'm gonna be using in my
art here so we're all kind of in this
together
Martha arts asks is it allowed to
texture the models or download the
background with these two hours yeah you
can model stuff and yeah you can texture
stuff how you'd like but you have to use
any number of these models that's it you
can't use any other models you can only
use the models in the pack we got a Ford
Focus P ghost you are keeping me active
and healthy no need to apologize
yeah y'all prep your textures this is
the time we're gonna start in like ten
minutes so download your stuff
download your stuff get your stuff
loaded in and we're gonna get going here
soon but don't start compositing don't
start building your scene until the
timer starts otherwise you cheatin you
cheatin alright we have a Japanese
Lantern here and again who knows that
this stuff is the scale nobody really
knows right
but in C 40 I'll spawn a figure to see
and that looks about right to me let's
keep going keep opening up our stuff
what else do we have in this model pack
we have a lady sitting it's kind of
creepy a little bit
but who knows maybe she's looking at
some cool view maybe she's on the top of
mountain looking down into the city
below who knows but we got that let's
keep going let's keep going
mannequins we got mannequins awesome
maybe you can do a creepy Silent Hill
scene let's keep it up we got an old
boat ye old boat cool I could see like
mannequins in a boat or that lady
sitting in the boat with her cat or
something guys we have a visitor a very
special guest it's Gilbert do you have
anything to say Thank You Gilbert we'll
watch from the sidelines or maybe he'll
just be all up in my business
nobody knows only Gilbert does hey
Gilbert Gilbert's excited Gilbert's very
excited for this rendered challenge he
does he steals this thing he steals this
pen and plays with it all night I've
done 20 20 burpees and I'm already
winded I know alright can you edit the
models yes you can edit the models that
is totally fine that is all good HD our
eyes are allowed yes guys that's all
good you just have to use the models
provided that's it you can't use any
other models but you can use any
whatever else you want you just got to
use some of the models provided to make
a scene so let's keep going what else do
we have provided for everybody
if you guys saw Porco Rosso oh my
goodness
CG studio you're gonna kill me if you do
this for every super chat you can't
focus on work by the way
I Love You Man you know what I can't
focus on work because when you're off
doing workouts you know your mind can
wander and then in that time that's when
you come up with some crazy ideas
because you're not thinking about what
you're doing you know you'll get shower
ideas you'll get you'll get dream ideas
but um okay let's do know 10 keep
downloading those models guys let's get
those models going
I know okay
in the almond oh okay I'm not stopping I
will not stop I've been in quarantine
for a week now and I must get my
activities going so um every super Chad
is ten burpees you know if you don't
want me to do it don't don't do it guys
that's on you um okay we got an airplane
maybe we'll use that let's keep going
ooh
okay we got a refinery this kind of is
cheating cuz it's kind of a scene
already so how about this let's um just
use the refinery that's what I'm that's
what I'm God dang these almonds because
that's what I meant to include was just
the refinery
oh so we'll delete the ground plane will
delete the tree because that's gonna be
cheating y'all that's gonna be cheating
okay
this thing's super cool isn't this would
be a nice little background asset or
something
techno what are you asking uh
can I make a VJ loop what is that I
don't know what that is as long as it's
using short animation dude if you guys
have time to make a short animation in
two hours
be my guest as long as it's posted
render rendered and posted within two
hours to any social media whatever I
don't care you know whatever you want
let's keep going what else do we have we
have a skeleton
let's take a look at this old skeleton
here oh it's rig just who very nice
awesome
all right what else do we have we have a
mirror standing mirror
Andres yes you can make your own models
if you'd like as long as you use some of
these models provided from the pack
and ya posted in discord that counts as
well do you guys want to post in the
discord chat and finally we have an
umbrella and that's all the stuff we got
so if you guys are ready give me a
thumbs up here if you have your models
ready to go like I do just give me a
thumbs up in the chat here and we will
start this timer we will begin
mm I wish I can get a little windowed
timer for all of us
I might just have to get this in here
somehow
so I'll encourage you guys to start your
own timer just so we're all uh we're all
on the same page here but I will have
one for reference for us all right we
got a lot of thumbs ups we bought ready
to go guys this is it I'm getting a
little nervous
all right so the rules are I I'm I mean
I've set them a million times here but
better over communicate and under
communicate right so we have two hours
once this timer begins here I'm gonna do
a little 3 2 1 everyone get their timers
ready right now because we're gonna do
it together we're gonna have to make a
scene using these models you can model
other stuff if you have time you can do
simulations whatever you want if you
have time but do not do not let this
challenge deceive you so basically
people came over to our studio we did it
in one hour it was super intense it was
really fun but the thing is you cannot
get caught up on details you're gonna
have to blaze through this process so
clear ok here focus on the general shape
of your scene and get your camera set as
soon as possible
get your composition build up your
composition of your elements don't even
worry about textures for right now
and these are just general tips here you
guys can do whatever you want but um
yeah start general then get specific if
there's time just remember you have to
render it and you have to post it within
the two-hour mark if you guys have an
Instagram make sure to tag me on
instagram with your image so I can share
it it's underscore punisher underscore
on Instagram yeah you guys can also post
it to the discord chat as well or the
discord channel the link is in the
description and we are about to get
ready here let's see let's see there's
no specific theme you can use whatever
models you want as long as you get
something done in two hours you have to
get it done in two hours that is the
whole point okay guys here we go five
four three two one and a half one and
begin alright
so I know I definitely want this oil
refinery this thing is super cool maybe
like hmm hmm let's see let's see
this boat could be sweet on the oil
refinery and you guys for everyone just
watching if there's any new viewers in
the chat asking yes Martin you can use
Forester if there's any new viewers in
the chat asking what the heck is going
on I'm gonna be pretty focused on this
over the next two hours if you all don't
mind just helping out let them know what
we're doing here letting them know that
you can download all these models for
free in the description of this video
and join us you know join along see if
you can get something done here in two
hours
hmm and I'm using the merge tool here
not merge tool but merge option to just
bring in different assets into the same
scene inside of c4d here
do my hand is shaking from all those
push-ups and for those of you just
joining yes I'm doing 10 burpees for
every super chat in the feed here still
winded from the last 30 let's see let's
see
oooh skeleton in the boat that's a
little dark yeah uhm mannequins in the
boat that could be interesting what
about this lady
I'm sorry it's too late in your country
I wish you well and and you know Kenny
no c4d is not the only program allowed
you can use whatever you guys want
anything you want I don't care if you're
drawing I know Melanie likes drawing so
if you're if you're trying to draw a
scene you got two hours all right and
it's got to be posted within two hours
let's keep bringing in some assets mmm
[Music]
maybe the cat we could just say this is
Gilbert
why is Gilbert not moving
hmm
so most of the models provided come with
OBJ's and FB X's and all of those you
should be able to open in other programs
why can't this cat move let's throw them
in a connect object no let's throw them
in a null object and that works and this
cat is massive
but we'll worry about scaling and all
that stuff a little later
hmm
ooh I wonder if like you can get some
like ice shelf going or something let's
see let's see here let's kill this guy
up and see can we get the adjust the sea
level and the plateau level something
like this
yeah lost show thanks for joining
get some sleep stay healthy get some
push-ups in stay active and yeah this
will be the video will be uploaded to my
to my channel here and as soon as the
livestream is done so all right let's
see is that too high sea level oh that's
interesting
whoa whoa that's awesome I don't know
you do that super cool all right I'm
trying to lower the size of this there
we go there we go
all right guys we are ten minutes in to
the to our render challenge download the
models if you hadn't already we got two
hours to render something cool with the
models provided if you don't have c40
will then use blender if you don't have
blender then use 3ds max if you don't
have 3ds max then use maya if you don't
have any of those well then grab a pen
and paper and start drawing build some
Legos whatever you must do to get
something cool out in time we got an
hour and fifty left David all good
welcome better late than never
what has been my strategy strategy to
stay in a good state of mind during
these times these times quarantine and
you know people being scared and stuff
trying to stay home trying to stay
healthy
well I love cooking honestly the more I
can get up and move the better like I do
enjoy going out for runs or yoga I do
love yoga as well so anything that gets
me up and moving is a good way to kind
of keep my a good state of mind good
peace of mind during these times that's
a good question what about yourself man
David what are you doing - stay saying
these days what are all you guys doing
to stay sane these days
all right we got our boat
mmm cliff might be a little large let's
see if we can bring this down a little
bit okay
mr. cat is asking if I'm ready to be
back at corridor well guys we're working
from home and honestly I do enjoy
working from home very much actually I
get distracted very easily so it's a lot
easier to focus and point point point
proven there yeah it's a lot quieter
it's been raining here in Pasadena so I
enjoy that very very much as well but
yeah we're we're all working together
from home staying happy and healthy
all right let's duplicate this here
refinery um let's do let's do like an
octane scatter here I got my camera
angled down let's see about I'm just
gonna make a plane and scatter it around
the plane here cuz I definitely don't
want to scatter it all around the
mountains because that would just that
would destroy the system this refinery
probably has a few polygons so we'll
just want to keep things reasonable
Tony says he's fortunate that this
hasn't changed his daily routine
I've worked from home for about six
years now but it's important to stay
active hydrated and healthy totally
agree totally agree it's really all
about working out for me at least if I
am still for too long I will go crazy so
I got to keep the workouts going so
let's see if we can't scatter this
refinery along the plane using octane
scatter if you guys don't have octane
you can also do it with a mograph cloner
and just choose object and scatter it
across the surface of that object but
I'm going to use octane scatter for now
so we're going to want to scatter the
refinery over the surface of this plane
here I'm going to turn off the scatter
for now because I don't want to blow up
the system and if you zoom in here you
should be able to see actually let's
turn that on you should be able to see
little dots
we only want like 20 of them now why is
it not scattering over this oh my
goodness I didn't even save my scene
that would've been bad save your scene
guys save your scene let's see let's see
all right
it's going to make room for the live
viewer here
how's everybody doing everyone thumbs up
if you're working on the model happy
face if you're enjoying the content here
guys
feel free to throw me questions actually
this is this is pretty chill I'm able to
read most of this here I got I got my
scene set up I got my idea so I think
now it's just kind of getting it into a
place where it looks nice once you get
your idea it's it's uh it's not too bad
you just don't want to get hung up on
the details focus on the composition
okay and my day is going well my days
going very well I got a four mile run in
I'm training for a half marathon I got
some burpees in as some of you guys saw
we're doing every super check gets ten
burpees in the spirit of activity and
trying to stay healthy during quarantine
time all right let's get this thing
scattered okay let's get this thing
scattered around
what version of Achtung am i using that
is a good question I believe it's the
most recent version of octane
um so it looks like it is scattering
it's just not displaying it on the plane
here for whatever reason usually it
displays it with like a little align as
you guys can see but I don't know why
it's not oh I bet you I know why I
probably have it turned off here
no everything's on I don't know why it's
not showing us the dealy maybe you have
to make the editable no who knows but as
you can see we have our refineries going
in the viewer there so let's um let's
randomize these guys a bit
and see what it looks like from camera
view that's pretty sweet yeah that's
pretty sweet
so I have these lights on the refinery
which is really going to add to the
ambiance of everything we will fix that
issue later let's just keep building out
the general feeling of our scene here
my goodness CG studio appreciate your
brother hit me with that super chat
we're gonna do another 10 burpees for
you
CG studio this is for you for any of you
guys joining along
let's get those 10 burpees and let's get
back to it
make sure we got the camera on here we
got proper form y'all on you that proper
form it guys a burpee is a jumping jack
into a push-up all right now let's move
CGT studio oh man these calories these
calories that are disappearing right now
are for you and the other five burpees
are for the rest of y'all oh and I lost
count
good luck ah jeez ah in the almond mmm
it's a good day off it is a good day
CG studio I appreciate you thanks for
the UH
the health benefits we got to keep
moving in these times of quarantine
y'all it helps with the mental state and
helps with the physical it helps with
everything oh goodness I'm losing it
okay
oh let's keep moving let's keep moving
I'm diggin the scene so far I'm just
sitting here watching your exercise
we'll eat my chips Knowles I'm that's
that's cool man
I'm down I'm down for that make sure to
get out and just do some push-ups or
something you know while you're in
quarantine cuz we will lose our minds if
we don't take care of our bodies horse
I'm glad you caught this stream as well
this is a good one we're all doing a
little render rendered Ely together guys
what's that what time do we have what
time do we have
we're about 23 minutes in to our to our
render challenge how's everybody doing
right now hopefully you guys have some
sort of scene setup here it has to be
posted I'm gonna pass away on this one
guys it has to be posted within the two
hour time limit we got an hour and 36
minutes left all right
let's keep it goin all right um okay so
I got y'all know me I'm all about that
fog but let's get some ocean vibes up in
here so there is a plugin called hot for
D and E Abram Abram I don't know C for D
can you also do Maya you know I have
three months worth of my experience I
don't think I can do Maya
right now I'm in C for day the C for D
these days but um guys real quick let's
make a little ocean thing there's a
really cool plugin for cinema 4d called
hot 4d and it stands for Houdini ocean
something basically you make a plane and
this is free guys it took me a while to
figure out there to find the download
link but I will provide that for you
guys at the end of this stream here you
basically make a plane
alright alright and let's go into solo
viewports solo here and with the plane
selected I believe let's go up to
plugins where are you at hot for D there
you are and I believe you make the plane
a child or is it the other way around
how does this work
oh wait I have the wrong plane selected
wait do I I'm confused
there we go there it is okay so you can
see it kind of gives you this like ocean
look right here now if you tweak the
settings basically what it's doing is
it's using some pretty cool displacement
textures to displace the geometry here
and it can get pretty crunchy but check
it out it also should animate yeah it
animates really well actually and now
this is certainly a low poly version
let's um let's up these samples here so
ocean resolution this is when it gets a
little chunky but let's go to 1024 wait
okay so I'm gonna set the ocean
resolution to 512 for now I'm gonna go
into my plane and just set this to 100
by 100 the more samples you have the
more polygons you have the better this
is going to look so as you can see this
is already starting to look pretty sweet
and once again it does it does animate
like ocean waves and if you take it to
the next level let's say 200 by 200 and
then you set the ocean resolution a
little higher it will start to really
look pretty sweet here but then you see
it's chugging right
but we only need it for a frame right we
don't need it to to animate so that's
pretty choppy let's take the ocean let's
see let's see shortest wavelengths wind
direction approximate wave height there
you go it gets you a pretty cool look
right there choppiness set that to 1
what does that look like let's set it to
20 okay so you really get like some
foamy folding stuff here choppiness
let's just go to at 1.5 oh you're on the
rendering stage Timothy man flying by
that's awesome that's awesome man
what can you do to maybe add a little
bit more detail at this point you know
we have an hour and 30 minutes left what
can you do to spice it up all right all
right so this is a nice little ocean
scene here let's get the chop back to
one wavelength we'll go 20
and even you're right we can't do normal
normal map here if we with low-poly
ocean and now that would actually
probably be I'd be a good good source of
not good source that'd be what am I
trying to say good you see your RAM good
use of your probably done count and
everything but I don't have ocean maps
right now so I'm gonna keep going with
what I got so where's the camera gonna
be roughly right here okay pretty low
which is good for us because when we're
low we don't see too far into the
background let's take the camera the
boat and the water and let's all move it
up a little bit so we can have a bit
more room the boat the ocean and the
camera will all move up to get you got
these almonds guys man okay so then our
ocean will just kind of move it around
we'll change the seed yeah that's that
feels about right maybe bring the ocean
down a little
nice and the boat will kind of maybe
like
I like that profile that's pretty nice
sweet okay
not bad not bad so let's get the
lighting down that's the next most
general thing that we need to do is get
the lighting down
I think textures is the last thing I'm
going to do all right
so y'all know me I do love my fog so
let's see let's load in an HDRI image
here oh man that looks so cool that
looks awesome
all right here actually here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna make sure I can get
the lights on this refinery looking
proper so let's take off the octane
scatter
hmm
so I'm gonna try and adjust these lights
here so that they're all properly being
this whole scene is properly being lit
because I think that's gonna add a lot
to the atmosphere as the lighting so I'm
going to spend some time on getting this
right but it doesn't have to be exact
Abram yeah so is asking to explain
displacement maps so displacement maps
are black-and-white images that you use
to push and pull the polygons of a model
so for instance with the the ocean setup
that I had right basically I start with
a plane subdivided however many by
however many and the more polygons you
have the more detailed the displacement
map will be the better the displacement
map will look as it pushes and pulls the
polygons because it has more it has more
to play with right does that make sense
so you can use it for a number of
different things you know they're good
to use when you're trying to save memory
or RAM right so instead of modeling an
entire thing you'll use at one image to
push and pull the polygons and it'll
save you actually a lot of time a lot of
render time and whatnot so yeah it's a
nice little a little tip is using
displacement maps instead of detailed
you know turbosmooth models and geometry
and whatnot so I'm just trying to select
this last light here and then I'm gonna
copy all these lights and move them up
and then it looks like the rest of these
lights are basically good
everybody doing alright maybe got some
music going learning a thing or two you
guys enjoying yourselves so what is that
this light is huge but I think that's
all right sweet yeah this is all lit and
looking good so now we need to make sure
the lights actually scatter properly so
maybe we throw this refinery into a
connect object
and then we scatter the connect so the
lights are staying there
weird why is that not scattering
properly well let me
so that's buggy for sure let me try
scattering it instead of with octane
I'll try scattering it with the the c4d
cloner
looks like that's kind of working okay
but they're all laying down um ooh and
we're chugging um Kula asked if we can
use other models really wanna use that
bucket that you showed I know it's not
part of the pack well you can model a
bucket real quick right now the
challenge is to use the models provided
to make a cool scene but you can model
stuff if you if you'd like to to model
something that is all good and a book it
should be pretty easy to model yeah all
right let's set this cloner - let's see
let's see is it so what's the difference
between instance render instance and
multi instance I should know this right
and we certainly want to give it that
same random randomizer that we had on
the octane one let's see what that looks
like from camera view not bad you might
just want to move the plane over so that
it's more centralized and then maybe
give it like let me grow the plane a
little bit so it's spread out a bit more
that's pretty sweet
I hope did I lose connection you guys
still there
Oh
y'all still there I think we may have
lost connection a little bit
is everybody alive I don't know if we
lost connection or not let's find out
okay got you guys
sweet right about that
so yeah Abram uh yeah ask ask away I am
available for questions guys we are in
hour and 16 minutes into our render
challenge the other way around were 40
minutes into the render challenge and I
got to get my lights going here gotta
get the lighting set
all right um so let's get an HDRI going
man that looks awesome I look so cool
so in a month a welcome you're still
here
guys so Demonte really took the discord
channel to the next level so check out
the discord channel he did a really good
job the link to that is in the
description of this video go there post
your work when we're done here post your
work to that and Justin writer with the
ten bucks for ten burpees $1 Burpee he
says he'll join in with you on this one
for once thanks for making Saturday so
awesome with your stream keep being
awesome Justin thank you so much for
keeping the spirits of physical fitness
alive I really appreciate your donation
it helps out in these times so yeah 10
burpees for you brother and whoever else
is trying to stay physically fit in this
time of quarantine it's important to get
up and move so every super chat is 10
burpees so let's get to it
and for those of you guys who watch
corridor crew I'm actually gonna be
filming like a little workout routine
and the yoga routine that you guys can
do from home well you're at home because
most of us are stuck at home in my
Chester this is good I think I think
that's thin but one extra in the almond
of course Justin thank you
I needed that has do the rest of us got
to stay fit and happy and healthy oh God
do we oh oh goodness
okay it's hard to breathe okay let's
keep going guys this is looking pretty
friggin sweet I'm very happy with this
look right now let's let's load an hgri
into this business
oh I'm sorry how I'm not breathing my my
sweat into this mic here oh okay let's
do this let's make this nice I mean that
looks cool that looks cool but you guys
know I am a sucker for the foggy
atmospheric vibes and if you guys are
ever loading HDRI images into octane and
they're coming in looking like this
basically all you need to do just click
on the image and set the color profile
to linear and they'll even things out a
bit whoo all right
Abram is asking but one of my something
didn't subdivide and still got details
wild this placement and Arnold how's it
done
well usually you might need to tone down
this the displacement map that setting
because it will get insane you just need
to bring it down to a very small level
like point one point two point three
start small and also up the higher the
resolution the more detailed it will be
so I don't use Arnold but it's a little
it's a little similar I know you're
talking about it looks like a spiky ball
or something yeah you just need to tone
down the displacement map set your
midpoint to 0.5 or something all right
this is the grayscale gorilla space HDRI
pack
this isn't out yet but they were kind
enough to send me send me this this pack
for you guys give a little preview
it'll be out a little later this year
maybe in a couple months or so and god
dang it unreal you're killing me you are
you are killing me but you're keeping me
healthy ten more
he says been a fan since carbon warfare
appreciates you it's one of the reasons
I started doing VFX
so not much but here's a little
something dude I really appreciate you
thank you for the donation I'm gonna I'm
going to hate you momentarily while I do
these burpees but you know afterwards
I'm gonna be a better man so I
appreciate you man and I appreciate you
Gilbert's just sleep oh okay this is
great this is just great we're wearing
my glasses
unreal appreciate your brother thank you
yeah we got Gilbert where's the areas
right in the background he's sleeping
like a little little puffball Oh random
rotation welcome we're doing a render
challenge everyone has the same assets
we got an hour and eight minutes left so
far I got my composition and now I'm
just working the lighting every super
chat is ten burpees you know it's a pain
but we're trying to stay active during
this quarantine time I hope all you guys
are staying healthy
staying safe crazy times huh really
weird times right now but um you do what
you got to do you know for the greater
good so I'm just trying to promote a
little bit of a healthy activity here in
the meantime we all need it it's true we
all need to stay more active and I'm a
huge believer in physical fitness
helping out with mental fitness so the
more you do you just get out there feels
good it feels good to clear mind okay
let's set up these textures here on the
boat so we want what is this I don't
know what that is I'm actually pretty
happy with the position of the lady
right now the umbrella
the umbrellas fine maybe a little large
something like that feels good the boat
the boat needs textures let's scale it
up a little bit knife is cooler cooler
it was small meet Aruba welcome welcome
to your first stream this is a pretty
fun one you know we're all doing a
little Renner challenge together got to
be posted within two hours so yeah let's
let's load the textures for the boat
here
all right
here we go
so for some reason octane will crash
cinema4d when I drag over textures from
the desktop sometimes sometimes but it
looks like right now I'm getting lucky
not be sewell do I like Houdini I've
never used to Jeannie but I've always
wanted to use Houdini so maybe in the
future maybe in the future and I know
greyscale gorilla has some pro training
for Houdini so pardon me
so may yeah maybe in the near future
maybe during this quarantine time is the
time to learn some Houdini and honestly
guys like take advantage we got take
advantage of the time that we have if
we're all you know cooped up in our
houses you know definitely get out get a
walk get going and stuff but also take
the time to learn something new you know
definitely take the time to learn
something new okay let's see if we can't
get some fog going up in the scene here
I mean aruba's asking what the heck is
up with my mouse movement I'm on this
pen tablet here
it's a Wacom Pro into a four tablet it's
the best it saves my wrist when I'm
doing a lot of work especially now
working from home so yeah good way to
good way to save the wrist okay for the
boat we don't need the oars
let's get
oh man have you guys ever seen children
of men you guys remember the ending of
that movie with the boat in the fog
because I sure do and if we can get
those vibes that would be a win so let's
see if there's a greenish yeah we got
this like greenish alien sky
that might work that's kind of the vibe
um let's get like an icy texture over
these mountains back here
and it's gonna be let's see it's gonna
be mostly covered in in fog these
mountains so it's actually not the
biggest deal to get these things like
super detailed but
we're going to go for it you know
hmm
have I tried bridge like Adobe bridge is
that what you mean cool
what's our time at we have 59 minutes
left everybody 59 minutes left to get a
render posted posted
Oh quick sabrage yeah quick soul is
basically the best thing ever allows you
to automatically import materials for
mega scans and plugins for the materials
I think oh they have a c4 do you plug-in
oh my goodness I am definitely gonna
have to look into that because I thought
it was only for unreal and like like
another renderer or something I didn't
know they had a c4 do you plugin I will
definitely definitely definitely look
into that it's most certainly okay so
with a bit of fog I think we can really
take this to the next level and actually
here's a quick tip for you guys let's
see if this works so I saw people do
this oh man that looks so cool Wow we'll
have to see if a lake would look cooler
because that right there dude that looks
awesome but um here's a quick tip for
you so Bay this is like easy fog or um
quick fog basically all you want to do
is make a plane a large plane scale it
way way up and it's basically going to
cover your entire background and this
this example worked at night time when
people did it but basically you get it
like real close you scale it up so it's
your entire background and then you
basically just shine an area light at
the background
let's turn this thing around point it up
and make sure you hide the light from
the renderer
and we'll scale the light up
and it's gonna point it's gonna point
straight up at the background and it
looks like fog
it looks like fog in the background so
this works for like say a night scene or
something right now like it's totally a
vibe you know but our foreground we need
some fog in our foreground we need to
bring out our subject here so let's see
just adjusting my camera settings
that's actually pretty cool it's a
pretty cool look we can set the light to
more of like a blue or something like
8000 and the lights on the refinery I
feel like they need to come up
but I think at the end of the day guys
we need some fog in our scene so I'm
gonna hide I'm gonna hide this light and
the plane that we made that was a good
test we might come back to that but
let's see about let us see about adding
some actual fog here
all right oh no Martin hang in there man
save often I'm sorry I'm sorry buddy
that's rough his octane just crashed it
happens to the best of us all right so
with octane fog we talked about this
last week but basically you bring it in
and it can crash your system pretty hard
because it is very render intensive so
the first thing I do I will pause my
live viewer and the second thing I'll do
is under the volume settings change the
voxel size editor to 100 and we can even
go 200 basically that just takes up less
of your viewport juice right so we're
gonna scale this up and we want to
position this fog just so it's touching
our foreground subject here we'll move
it back a little bit reach it out again
I think that's a good amount and
unfortunately we're gonna have to
stretch it beyond the bounds of our
scene here like we're gonna have to
really stretch this thing out so I
usually hide it in my viewport so I can
see what's going on and then I'll set my
live viewer settings here I'll just set
my width and height to something very
small 400 by 225 right save your scene
and this little lock button if you click
that once all right let's turn it off
let's render our scene
and when you click the lock button that
basically locks the aspect ratio in the
resolution to the live viewer here so
most likely yeah we're gonna see
darkness here because the fog is too
thick and the computer is thinking it's
thinking let's hit the lock button so
it's just that small little area we're
on path tracing not direct lighting
we'll go to medium we'll go in here and
we'll just take the density down to
point one it's still it is still super
thick so let's take the absorption let's
go with like a off-white like almost
greenish white let's just try white okay
and then let's take the scattering let's
make that the kind of greenish color
interesting so it's like not quite sure
what it's doing there it's turning it
blue so our fog is certainly too thick
still even at point one it's still too
thick let's go to 0.05 and we can start
to see our background here let's um
let's actually switch out let's switch
out our background let's do let's turn
back on that plane and the light and I'm
going to turn the light instead of blue
I'm gonna keep it at 5,600 um and you
know what let's go warm with it let's go
3200 and let's still bring the fog down
it's still actually let's take our
scattering phase and just crunch it up
basically that's going to allow the
light to blast through the fog a little
bit more it's gonna have light will have
a bit more shape let's still take our
fog down so 0.05 let's go point oh two
five wow this is looking cool 0.015 and
there you can start to see the shape of
everything coming in that's looking real
cool so let's um adjust our ocean here
I'm gonna scale this back up
let's go like 700 toggle the lock back
on and back off and let's turn the fog
off for a second and just focus here on
water in the foreground so I want to get
that shape right so I'll choose the a
little render region box select that and
how much time do we have
we have 48 minutes left plenty of time
to tweak a couple things
um render and then I'll show you guys my
my process in Photoshop and how I like
punch up the renders a little bit so
yeah it's looking a little like silky
smooth here and I'm not really a fan of
that vibe right now so I'm gonna go into
my the texture I made for the ocean
there and just take the roughness back
down to zero and then I'm going to
adjust the ocean here so let's see maybe
just the height
and it's thinking it's thinking real
hard
let's adjust I'm gonna double the
resolution we might be gearing up for
some problems here but the doubled
resolution yeah that should make things
a little nicer now she is floating in
her boat so let's bring her down
let's see about adjusting the ocean size
a little bit let's go to a thousand okay
that's weird
um 250 I'm just kind of messing with the
settings here
weird okay so any direction I go what
graphics card amazing I'm using a gtx
1070 just one of them just one gtx 1070
ooh that feels a little better it feels
a little better
dude matthias knows or Mathis
hmm so we got call motion we got a
choppy ocean
all right not bad not bad so we have
like the the reflection from the
refinery hitting the water which looks
really nice and we have the light
bouncing off the top of the umbrella
which is super nice but I wonder if like
there needs to be some sort of light
source inside of this boat here but also
remember we guys we had a cat inside of
this boat right let's find that where's
the cat
wait what happened to the cat rip in PI
this is asking where I'm posting these
renders in the end I usually post on my
instagram @ underscore punisher
underscore boom and when you guys are
done with your vendors tag me in your
render and i'll feature it on my page in
the story and and yeah because we're all
here while doing cool work right now so
why not so the cat i don't know where
the cat is guys it has disappeared
let's try reloading it
I'm gonna have to render in the next
five minutes or so because it's gonna
take a minute and if you guys don't have
Instagram that's all good just post it
somewhere if you have to post it to the
discord chat that goes along with these
live streams please do please please
please do okay so I think the cat the
cat got stuck up here
oh man that's another 10 burpees guys
hello from Croatia Milan Cara costs
tutorials I hope you got some good
tutorials but thank you for joining and
thank you because now that you've super
chatted I must do 10 burpees in the sake
of fitness and health in the times of
quarantine right now we got to keep this
mind healthy and fresh so let's do some
more burpees guys show you guys how do
that thing
yeah whatever you look oh that's like
okay like that's like 70 burpees and the
almond of course okay hmm I might have
to just forget this cat here cuz I can't
move this thing for some reason oh there
we go they're real so with the cats
selected I can pretty easily just hit
the what is this tool the transfer tool
and then click the boat and the cat will
transfer to the boat
let's see hit the cat transfer tool and
it should why is it not working
this cat is all walked out guys it's
also it's also massive oh no one it
doesn't scale properly we're down to the
wire okay when things don't scale
properly all you have to do guys is type
it out in the little coordinates dialog
box and you'll get a proper proper scale
there know why come on cat this thing's
just gonna have to be black but these
eyes are killing me let's just turn it
away there we go
that's cool
time how much time we have 38 minutes
left to finalize your renders I'm about
done here let's turn the fog back on and
see what this is looking like you guys
notice that like I didn't even texture
the factory because it's not needed you
know I know that it's gonna be in the
background it's gonna be in fog and at
the end of the day so it's not really
needed I might choose a different focal
length here for the camera I might just
adjust the sizing of it a little bit
definitely do some color correction in
Photoshop hmm who was asking Clint I
just sent you a link to the mega skeins
playing on discord so you can have a
look after the stream in case you forget
thanks koa and to those of you guys who
are not part of this live stream discord
channel it's awesome our very own so
Demonte like fix it up nice for you guys
it's it's really cool really awesome
it's a very cool place for a lot of
people to go and like share their work
ask any questions get tips and all this
and that from different community
members there's a 3ds max blender cinema
4d all bunch of different programs bunch
of different people who are messed
around in those programs so if you guys
are looking to up your game then
definitely join the discord channel yeah
this is this is looking cool I think I
want to adjust the position of the woman
here
to get a better silhouette right you
want to be able to tell what is going on
so let's just kind of move her around
until we think we can tell that there's
someone here that there's something
going on yeah that's not bad
and then let's take this light that's
blasting up against this solid back here
let's just turn it up to a hundred
because we can always bring it down and
I definitely want to make sure the
lights from this thing are shining
through so I'm gonna render a quick
little render region of just the the
factory back here and it looks like it's
difficult to see the lights that are
shining so let's um let's turn those
things up let's see let's see let's see
so I'll basically hit render here pretty
soon
I'll give it like ten minutes to render
and I can answer any questions during
that those ten minutes really focus on
the questions that you guys have and
then we'll hop into Photoshop and finish
the image let's see what kind of cool
looks we can get but yeah those lights
definitely aren't showing through so
let's get those working
and really trying their best to shine
through that fog there
hmm for whatever reason the lights are
having a tough time maybe it's cuz the
okay maybe it's because this is
reflective
yeah this is weird you see this guy's
it's like giving me it's like speckled
look should be doing a better job
what is causing that what is causing
that hmm
you know half of EF X's troubleshooting
figuring out why something's not working
that's so weird it's just taking so long
I don't get it it was working before we
might just you might just not have time
and it might just be a matter of a
certain amount of samples
I'm stumped
a coal thanks for the share man
appreciates you and I'm really glad that
you guys are enjoying these streams we
got record amount of viewers here we had
150 last week we got 146 like concurrent
you know like it's going through the
entire time here so it's very very cool
[Music]
but my computer is thinking very hard
right now hopefully it doesn't crash if
it does well basically just have to hit
render when we boot back up I'll answer
any questions you guys have and then
we'll do Photoshop
we'll wrap this thing out and post it
because we have 28 more minutes guys I'm
starting to feel the heat now it is
official I'm getting a not responding
from c4d closing down booting back up
[Music]
this is about it
oh no the cat got all wonky again shoot
come on ooh
starting to feel it keyboarding man
these almonds keyboarding appreciate you
thank you thank you all right let's get
this rendered and then actually take a
look at some of you guys as stuff in the
discord chat
man yeah this cat is just not it's not
working it makes me sad we'll try it one
more time and then we got a render or
else
awesome awesome all right let's give
this guy a render how's everybody doing
you guys finished with your stuff has
everyone rendered as well
you
all right all right I'm going to use the
greyscale gorilla space pack
oh I like that very much that is cool
ah
all right guys yep okay I'm getting a
little indecisive here towards the end
maybe we'll just add some stars after
the fact and yeah I think this will be a
thing that we can all do maybe once
every month or something maybe every
other week we can do a render challenge
together you guys look just let me know
like I think this has been pretty fun
this has been a good time all right I'm
gonna have to render this thing
alright rendering now I don't think I
have any choice I think it's time or
maybe do I throw a light up under here I
might be going insane guys I might be
losing my mind is there time nobody
knows we're down to the wire we have 20
minutes left 20 minutes left I got to
start rendering or I'm gonna lose it
all right let's make this a warm light
will go with 3200 oh my goodness Bourbon
Plus rendering equals burpees okay
I'm gonna hit render unreal and I'm
gonna start rendering this thing man
much appreciated much much appreciated
my brother just a little bit a light to
kind of fill in this foreground
Oh
alright enough enough with the tweaks I
can't tweak anymore
but I can't stop tweaking guys it's bad
nope alright no light we're doing it I'm
just hitting render 1280 by 720 current
frame let's save it as an e XR 32-bit
yes please all right how many samples do
we want
1200 will do 1200 samples will turn on
oh my goodness
2020 burpees that's a that's ten burpees
for each super chat you guys are crazy
turn on a little turn on adaptive
sampling save it and blast off fingers
crossed we're rendering this thing we
don't have something for the cat okay
whatever we'll deal with it later
alright unreal Thank You Erik thank you
in the spirit of both the all super
chats we're doing 10 burpees each that's
20 burpees in a row just rendered our
scene oh my god 30 burpees oh my good oh
[Music]
thank you guys I really really
appreciate you this is gonna render I
got 30 burpees to go I'll be back I'll
answer some questions I'll take a look
at your guys's art and and then we'll
talk about a little bit of Photoshop
what I do to tweak the image and yeah
we'll call it a day all right
or you guys gonna join me on some of
these or am I just got to do myself oh
my goodness that's ten 20 more to go
17
okay I know I got 10 more but in the
spirit of health and happiness let's uh
let's stay physically fit here while
we're in quarantine
get off that that couch don't be a
potato alright I got 10 more
eight nine
yeah Oh dirty
yes my girlfriend's out guarding right
now playing planes this is great it's
sunny outside I can't feel my arms or
rendering okay it's a good day
oh yeah
an almond for each super chat of course
one two three oh oh sorry I'll show you
look you know what you guys have made oh
oh
okay Seanie catch my breath here y'all
let's go to the disk or chat and let's
bring this thing over so well we got
project progress
y'all post it in here
what dude this looks so good
look at this mm-hmm this is Kim
everybody she's been hanging out yeah
this is this is awesome it looks like a
slide or something this is really good
um don't worry you guys if you missed
the stream or the challenge we'll be
doing this again this was a lot of fun
dang yeah mathis that is really good
cave of secret umbrellas very very nice
I don't know wise think it's long a load
that's awesome man yeah that's so good
and they have some Hogwarts vibes look
is the umbrellas so tiny compared to
like this one over here unless this
one's just like closer or something but
yeah this is this model looks really
good because it's a photo scan so it
looks real and yeah you got the lights
going into the cave that's super nice
good job on the ocean texture too and
you got some like fog down
and there's a little boat on the right
good work
eleven minutes oh my goodness
Timothy fantastic job oh my good what is
this Teela
whoa you got the airplane in there looks
like there's a skeleton there's bones in
the water I really like the mountains
back here these are really really nice
and you got the models here with the
laser eyes kind of like what are the
guys in Lord of the Rings that are like
holding up the hands you know it's kind
of that vibe very nice I got the crow in
there yeah great work let's keep going
ooh okay
this one was done in blender by techno
nice I guess it's a loop yeah you said
it was like a yeah it looks like a loop
you you start with these like two little
sharp points right here see these guys
they pass by and they pass by again yep
that's awesome very very cool you know
I've always wondered how to do something
like this I think that's great oh man we
got a lot of good ones guys so cool dude
blur on the macbook oh nice it's like an
upside down Christmas tree with lights
and like skeleton with the umbrella very
very cool
very nice what else what else and you
guys are awesome giving good good
compliments here ooh I like this there's
some story going on in this one this is
really nice
you got the girl who is a skeleton or
maybe that's like a portal or something
or I like that a lot
that is awesome I like the color too you
got some film green going very nice very
nice ooh someone used the Ford Focus
dancing skeletons oh man this is great
this is awesome this reminds me of like
a Mike Diva video very colorful I like
the like cartoony cel-shaded look yeah
umbrella with the crow Ford Focus it's
very its centered it's framed nicely
symmetrical framing love the background
I love the stars and everything this
one's super fun thank you I love it was
like didn't quite get through the render
that's super cool you can like tear the
edges like it's like a torn poster or
something you know this is nice
I like this a lot kind of reminds me of
Resident Evil a little bit it's a night
scene you lit it from underneath it's
very cool you got some lanterns going on
this thing this is great good work good
work love the black and white very very
much good silhouette you can tell like
what's going on here it looks like she's
in a cave silhouetted nicely there's a
tent here some steps going up to
somewhere and then a crow on a lantern
and it's a really really nice
composition here with the center circle
and the silhouette here that's great I
knew it was Mike teevee inspired heck
yeah it looks great
okay let's take a look ooh this reminds
me of if you guys know stews or on
Instagram he does a lot of cool renders
tangled is this tangled reference or
just remind you of tangled yeah this is
cool
yeah these like gushers there's these
glowing gushers in the water but the
mountains very very nice
dang this is awesome guys a whole bunch
there's like still more
let's check the renter's halfway done
and we have six minutes okay
let me get through this posting process
here because if I don't then I fail and
we'll go over the rest of the images
later I'm just gonna save this out as a
still image on the desktop
it's hop into Photoshop real quick guys
vagrant as soon as I'm done with this
post I'll answer that question that's a
good question if anyone has any advice
on that then you know give them a little
answer what can you do to get inspired
to make stuff so first thing I did is
content-aware fill out that little
banner okay so let's see I don't think
we need to really add any film grain but
let's do it anyway though so I basically
have like a film grain overlay that I
add on top of these things and there's a
Tmax 100 that's like a black-and-white
film stock
boom I said it's overlaying cuz it's
gray but I can't because we are in
32-bit mode so I need to go to 8-bit
don't merge and let's try that against
go overlay and let's see if we can't
like hmm what does this need what does
this need get started okay
let's boost up clarity here it's maybe
brightened things and bring the black
levels down
alright usually I like doing like a
little clamp so I'll go right here right
here right here and just move this up a
little bit so you lift the black levels
and I'll bring the shadows down blacks
down
and we'll add a bit of D haze to it and
we'll give it some vignette because
that's always nice or you know what
instead of that let's give it some
vignette from the bottom so I'll use the
graduated filter and come up we'll bring
the exposure down right there
ash in time I'm gonna get these I'm
gonna get this out and then I got you on
ten burpees
I appreciate you shouting out silk for
telling me to try this challenge with
them I really appreciate you for joining
it means a lot and we are racing the
clock here
all right let's go curves on this just
lift the blacks a little bit boom and is
it does it look better black and white I
always ask myself that it kind of does
it always usually does in a pinch I feel
like it does and then the last thing I'm
gonna do is just add a little bit of fog
on the ground here I'm gonna just use a
white brush kind of just do streak
across here and just bring the opacity
way down something like that and then
we'll come in here and we'll just erase
the area with the boat
boom and that's it now we save it and I
got to email it to myself and we're
gonna post it
we have 14 seconds oh my god I've to
post it in 14 seconds discord discord
discord come on come on come on just
dropping it in upload on the Pusser on
the buzzer oh my goodness
geez huh
guys that was intense we got more
submissions coming in let's take a look
at everybody's that was intense
I'll render out like a higher higher res
version for Instagram here but we got it
posted on the discord on the buzzer not
too happy with the color correction I
think it could be a bit more punchy in
the center there but we did what we
could do guys we did what we could do
where's the beeping coming from Wow okay
let's do 10 burpees for ash here
shouting out his friend xilk or zoo key
point him to the stream 10 burpees and
let's go over the rest of these images
here guys really really proud of
everybody for finishing and getting
these renders out man there's some
awesome stuff can't we do through all
this all right let's get a little
workout
Oh
we did it y'all we did an almond the
final almond hmm well that was fun that
was super fun so well if I get my camera
right I'm gonna go over the rest of
these images where I'm at
where am I here we go okay
dang y'all these are so cool there's so
many submissions hey Gilbert
oh that's Teddy hello Teddy this is the
other cat hello Teddy
dang this is rough
we're gonna airplane shot down the boat
is textured oh and you got a little
skeleton hand coming up the ground here
that's great
coral in the front ooh super foggy I
like this is like a futuristic city very
similar to my render here did the water
and the mountains in the background oh
sorry wrong screen yeah this is this is
awesome
applause we'll get you on the next one
man awesome awesome
ooh we got two uploads or is this just
in general here we'll do another one
later this is fun kind of reminds me of
Katamari I don't know this is part of
the render challenge or maybe it was but
you know just doing their own thing
which is cool
Gary didn't think you made it this looks
like an image to me I see a tulip or
something in in the ocean with these
sunken factories here and some mountains
in the background your play Lee game
flower kinda reminds me of that all
right what else what else this is
beautiful
looking out wow this is great the grass
in the foreground
very nice lighting very soft lighting I
love that I wonder if you had like an
area light over here and you just hit it
from the render or something then you
got your tower in the back very very
cool ooh oh this is great this is great
I love this big fan big fan I wish I
lived here who did this P Ghost very
good stuff man very very very good stuff
retro see what you got
whoa okay this looks like you are on the
moon you wrote a boat up to this Factory
on the moon and you got your crow here
you're white like crow and it's totally
again once again reminds me of Resident
Evil 4 in the lake with the was it the
del Lago they look huge
the huge like fish creature
yeah this is cool let's see did I close
did I close the chat where is everybody
at here
everybody's still with me
yeah we're still in what's up y'all
still going over all these images you
guys did such a good job rendering all
this awesomeness
all right I just want to make sure we're
still in here I'm still live streaming
I still got you guys still got everybody
I think I still got everybody yeah I
think I just close this window on
accident
all right we're still going still
reviewing all the awesome art this one's
sweet a little daylight scene the cat's
stranded here on the boat with the crow
just making their way to the closest
landmass possible fun fun little boss
town dynamics here very nice sulk sweet
some like shiny mannequins here very
interesting very creepy very Silent Hill
I like it
ooh this one's cool huh
got distracted with the grass
displacement hey it happens this is
awesome oh you got the motion blur and
they're in there as well that's super
nice I like the lighting very nice
lighting looks like you got a little
space HDRI as well
got the lantern in there that's very
nice
daylight scene kind of reminds me of
death straining a little bit that's
awesome very nice lanterns along the
creek here very very cool
what else what else we got what else we
got
this one this one Thunder Tiger this is
great really nice composition you got a
little film green action going I don't
know that's just you know render noise
or what but this is cool you have this
like spiral going down the umbrella this
is a really really nice piece of art I
like the way this like glares out down
here bottom left that's really nice I
love this yeah this one's a man this
one's great great work Thunder Tiger you
should be proud very proud oh this one's
crazy huh the demon demon crows on the
beach this is great very cool just the
wall of factories here got some sand
going down here very nice very nice all
right Ethan with this symmetrical
framing here I'm a big fan of that I
love this field it kind of reminds me of
breath of the wild a little bit one of
my favorite games of all time you get
the airplane Center focus here girl on
the boat you know I think it was just an
evidence girl on the boat here
that was kind of set up for a nice
little scene there great work y'all
let's see what is what is this well that
was cool that's super cool very anime
and there's more guys there's so much
this is awesome this is great yeah
here's a nice little one with the cat
chillin on the moon here good work
Ethan Andre us what do we got this is
awesome
super moody it looks real umm the
lighting is great nice use of depth of
field here this is awesome
fantastic work Andre its way to go
unreal
ok in blender awesome this is really
nice
you got some skeletons on the beach
nice little I want did you do the the
plane with the light blasting for the
background looks really really nice
great work this one's mine
I still need to tweak that contrast not
happy with the contrast but we'll get
that in a second skeleton on at the
night night out with skeleton here with
the umbrella and the factory super cool
love it
Gustav good work prop on shoe super
creepy skeleton here I like your
lighting very much cameras no Dark Souls
very very nice
oooh nice lighting super-creepy
Bladerunner vibes on this one good use
of all of the models here I notice oh
you use the chair but not the model that
was great that was great you got the
dresser a nice little interior scene I
like it a lot really like that one
good work neo cat Oh Marlo with a Blade
Runner looking scene here or actually
this is like a stews or looking scene if
you guys know stews or on Instagram this
is cool I like this a lot looks like a
creepy video game this looks like
Resident Evil Laser room that's awesome
very very cool a decor Dennis this is a
cool cool look here
Annie hot if you're having trouble
Posten your image all you have to do is
drag and drop it into the project
progress channel here the text channel
this is yeah this is so good
molto with little Ford Focus I can see
you've got it out just in time
very cool wow this is crazy oh you did
the same thing I did okay you took an
image of your render scene with your
phone that's what I had to do on the
last render challenge guys it happens
you know it happens and right now for
any of those of you guys just joining
we're reviewing all the work that we did
together here we were all given uh
models and we had to use those models to
make a cool scene and we had two hours
to do it
right now we are reviewing all the stuff
right now and it's under the chats me
hat is under chats right so it's under
the left on the left over here you got
chats and you got project progress um
all right well this is crazy I couldn't
even begin to start this lighting Wow
what this is insane the skeleton in the
mirror craziness craziness this one's
super cool very Stu's or Leo got the
skeleton with the umbrella flying
through yep this is great big fan whoa
that one's awesome it reminds me that
game it was the same the guy who did a
Shadow of the Colossus was named of that
game we have that like pet companion
yeah this is super cool I like this a
lot
great work exercise
sire stuff that I don't say that ooh I
love the low-poly look on this and I
love the colors and the composition
great work great work JV traum Nell I
think said that right yeah that's Tramel
awesome work oh this guy got the render
out very nice very nice nice nice
hodgepodge here you got the planes the
car got a whole bunch of stuff what is
this the the crow the lanterns good
stuff so I hope we're all learning stuff
as we're doing this you know and I hope
you guys are getting inspired to do some
more stuff
ooh so this is probably a displacement
map like we were talking about you can
see it's like looks all spiky but I
wonder if that was a render challenge or
if that was just a random random upload
blender beginner keep it up all right
this is creepy this is very creepy very
Silent Hill I like it a lot
dang you guys all you guys went to town
on this great work everybody fantastic
work
this is cool I like the texture on the
skeleton here looks like a toy I just
don't like play with it very creepy very
eerie Jonathan wow this is craziness I
don't think this is part of the Renner
challenge but cowork dude awesome
awesome awesome and that's it
that is it Neha you know you couldn't
find the chat but I got you here man
this is cool I like your your central
symmetrical framing here
very very nice good use of models here
using them in a pretty cool way I like
these mannequins back here the lighting
is super cool
and you got this like central light beam
going with some fog on the ground good
work man very good work very very good
work is that it do we have any more
let's check the c4d chat yeah okay
blender chat the general chat I think
that's everything guys fantastic work we
did it
so yeah we are all kind of in quarantine
for the next who knows how long so let's
just make sure we are making the most
use of our time being smart with our
time we're learning new skills so we can
come back to work better and stronger
and if you guys start to feel down if
you start to feel depressed or if you
start to feel you know isolated or
lethargic please just do some push-ups
do some crunches do some squats do some
yoga go out for a run go out for a walk
just get out take care of your mental
health I will be posting a workout in a
yoga routine on corridor crew
I believe in next week this upcoming
week here so look out for that I'm
really proud of everybody you guys did a
really good job you took all those
models you downloaded them we had like
40 submissions or something that was
super cool very proud of everybody yeah
keep it up keep it up thanks for all the
super chats I think did somewhere like
around a hundred burpees that was
awesome
I'm definitely sore can't wait to have
lunch what else guys yeah just stay
creative and stay passionate in these
times here we're all inside and if you
hadn't already joined the discord
Channel most of you guys have at this
point hit subscribe hit the little Bell
thingy they still have the Bell thingy
on YouTube I don't know it's been a
minute since I've been on YouTube guys
I've had my channel 4 G's since YouTube
started I think and I made a bunch of
short films to the cardboard warfare
series did that sleeping dogs fight film
a whole bunch of stuff and it took a
five-year break because I got signed on
to rocket jump and was very busy making
videos with Freddie at rocket jump and
then and now most of you guys know I'm
at corridor so I just don't have time to
focus on my channel and this is actually
a really cool and fun way to do it in a
very interactive way
to focus on my channel with you guys
amidst you know all of the busy the busy
work the busy time that I have because
it's a full-time job and it's very fun
keeps me on my toes so this is good
this is a good way for me to kind of
chill out and interact with you guys
anything else anything else yes
if y'all are looking for some fancy
photography prints you all know where to
go at this point basically but it's
noise green and light calm got these
prices down as much as I could for you
all but they're shipped out pretty
quickly if you guys are looking for some
nice art to fill the walls all y'all are
working from home I'm gonna see if I
can't get these prices down even lower
maybe we'll do some sort of sale or
something but yeah head on over here
take a look photos from all around the
world shot on film shot on digital but
that's all I got guys that's all I got
alright you guys I appreciate you very
much stay healthy stay happy and I'll
see you next Saturday well we'll do
something fun
once again alright guys peace